is glutamate acid good to take to help heal the gut.
So typically when you're healing the gut,
you would do glutamine.
So what's the difference with glutamate acid?
Well, both are amino acids.
But glutamate acid will convert to glutamate
and glutamine will convert to glutamate acid.
So there's not a whole lot.
But they technically are different.
Glutamic acid is an acid.
It has a carboxy group which makes it an acid.
But they do convert back and forth.
The negative of taking glutamine for cancer patient
is that glutamine can up-regulate cell reproduction
which is great to help heal the gut.
You want to up-regulate cell reproduction.
So you're probably do cells to help heal the gut.
But it's a negative for cancer patient
because it up-regulates cell reproduction.
You don't want to do that with a cancer patient.
The other negative of glutamic acid
and or glutamine in a product
is that they are also readily converted to glutamate.
The glutamate is a neurotransmitter.
So the glutamates are excitatory neurotransmitters.
And you do need them.
Your body will convert glutamic acid and glutamine
through several genes.
One of them is the GAT, GAT gene
to glutamate in order to make enough neurotransmitters.
You need neurotransmitters.
However, the problem usually entails people making
too much glutamate because of too much glutamine
and having defects in the GAT gene.
So they readily convert glutamine to glutamate.
And as our food supply typically has a lot of glutamates,
we have the problem that we have is not typically too little glutamate.
It's most commonly too much glutamate,
too high of a concentration of glutamates.
Most common glutamate found in foods is monosodium glutamate,
NMSG, but glutamic acid is also an excitatory
neurotransmitter itself and it's used in food.
So a lot of times you'll see glutamic acid
is an additive in foods because they don't want to list NMSG
because people have a negative connotation of NMSG,
which they should because excess NMSG
is going to cause excess glutamate in the brain.
It causes excitatory increase excitatory
to our transmitters in the brain,
which can cause OCD, anxiety, depression,
all sorts of issues, brain issues,
increased brain inflammation.
It's a very nasty player.
So people with any type of brain inflammation,
people with any type of brain issues whatsoever,
meaning they have early Parkinson's,
they have depression, they have anxiety,
they have OCD issues, they have dementia issues,
they should stay away from excitatory neurotransmitters.
They should stay away from glutamic acid,
they should stay away from glutamates.
And they should stay away from doing anything
that's going to increase inflammation of the brain.
They should stay away from dyes, food dyes.
It's got to look at testing for food sensitivities
and stay away from anything that is causing
an increase in inflammation.
So is glutamic acid good to help heal the gut?
Well, glutamine would be the source
of the gut healing product, not glutamic acid,
because this glutamic acid would convert
to glutamate quicker than glutamine would.
So I think the answer to this question will be don't.
Second answer to this question,
even if you're taking glutamide to help heal the gut,
I would say don't.
It's glutamide okay to take for somebody
to heal the gut who doesn't have cancer.
Yes, but still in low concentration.
So some products that you buy over the market
that's a powder that has,
often you're taking five grams of glutamated
that to heal the gut.
Well, I guess taking an issue for a very short period
of time would be okay, but excess,
it's still going to convert to glutamate,
but more readily if people have added defects
and it's going to cause all sorts of emotional issues.
So I would still be very careful with that.